this is not the first time this rohingya
have been forced from their homes years
ago they fled oppression in Myanmar
now a major fire at Cox's Bazaar refugee
camp in Bangladesh has again left
thousands without roof over their heads
in these three comes with the fire
happened around 100
000 Refuge
Refuge them or children you understand
the partners we are on the ground and we
are trying to meet the immediate and
Urgent meat of all those traumatized
children and their families
firefighters and volunteers were able to
get the plays under control but by then
there had been extensive damage
eight groups have been Distributing
water and basic necessities but it's not
clear whether those left without homes
will find shelter Cox's Bazaar is home
to more than a million rohingya refugees
a camp this size with so many living in
cramped condition makes fires like this
difficult to avoid during the dry season
it is quite easy that something catches
fire if if there's a distraction why
because the materials that we use in the
camps are all temporary meaning that the
shelters are built of bamboo enter
Poland which makes it quite easy that
something catches fire and the spread
can be also quite fast considering that
it's very congested and every shelter is
very tight with each other
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of rohingya fled a
military Crackdown in Myanmar that began
in 2017. years later it still isn't safe
for them to return while the fire
confirms conditions in the refugee camps
are dangerous those living here have
nowhere else to go tanvi chaudry Al
Jazeera Dhaka